c'è un termine che utilizziamo sempre
più spesso ultimamente è un termine che
a che fare con qualcosa che facciamo
magari anche inconsapevolmente però che
in qualche modo crea un impatto sulla
modalità poi successiva di evolvere gli
eventi questo termine sperimentazione
ho fatto una ricerca su google per
capire cosa significa questo termine e
ho capito che nello scenario
nell'immaginario collettivo questo
termine richiama a una serie di ampolle
di provini di provette sostanze che si
mischiano ad altre sostanze combinazioni
di materiali volte a cercare dei
risultati inediti in qualche modo
funzionale ad altri risultati a un
processo di ricerca che facciamo quindi
qualche modo sperimentazione a che fare
con ricerca con analisi con sviluppo con
il concetto di laboratorio per estendere
questa definizione
sono andato a consultare il vocabolario
che dice che sperimentare vuol dire
mettere alla prova un qualcosa per
accertarne per verificarne le capacità
funzionali l'efficienza l'efficacia il
rendimento
ora che cos'è questo qualcosa se non una
passione un idea un talento un istinto o
una capacità inespressa in fondo
sperimentare un'attività che facciamo
sin da quando nasciamo in qualche modo
veniamo scaraventati all'improvviso
nella vita senza nessun manuale delle
istruzioni senza nessun preavviso e
quindi tutto ciò che incontriamo lungo
il percorso ci è nuovo
abbiamo necessità di metterlo alla prova
abbiamo necessità di sperimentarlo e
quindi siamo tutti dei grandi
sperimentatori da bambini e quanto più
il bambino sperimenta durante il
processo di crescita quanto più
acquisisce degli strumenti che saranno
necessari in futuro per fare le
decisioni giuste
poi accade che maturando diventando
adulto
abbiamo necessità di confrontarci con
gli altri di inserire le nostre attività
nella società e in qualche modo dobbiamo
stare ad una serie di compromessi sono
una serie di ruoli di verità tate per
assoluto di strutture di di schemi
mentali anche che dobbiamo dare per
assodato che però dobbiamo rispettare
che sono necessarie per il bene della
collettività
però al tempo stesso in qualche modo
hanno come effetto collaterale un
appiattimento dell'espressività
individuali quindi anche quella capacità
di coltivare quell'unicità che
appartiene a tutti quanti questo
processo porta nel tempo questa mancanza
di sperimentarsi porta nel tempo ad una
mancanza anche di conoscere se stessi e
questa assenza di conoscenza ci mette in
difficoltà nelle scelte più importanti
della vita
non sappiamo dove andare che fare ci
sono delle strade da scegliere quindi
veniamo consigliati verso le strade più
opportune quelle che fanno tutti e
andiamo in crisi in qualche modo come io
sono andato personalmente in crisi
quando al termine del mio percorso
universitario
mi laureo come architetto massimo dei
voti
il percorso giusto quello che fanno
tutti è quello di fare un esame di stato
iscriversi all'albo poi successivamente
iniziare a fare pratica la gavetta
lavorare per uno studio bene ci ho
provato l'ho fatto ho lavorato in uno
studio meraviglioso ci aveva una una
vista verso il golfo di napoli
bellissima computer splendidi una
bellissima scrivania un bel lavoro però
in qualche modo io non mi sentivo felice
ero depresso
io andavo al lavoro ogni giorno con
l'ansia che mi mangiava le budella stavo
male dovevo fare qualcosa
ecco in questo caso la crisi può essere
un momento di evoluzione
anziché scegliere il percorso insomma
consueto di ascoltare anche se sono
possono essere i consigli saggi
apparentemente però quello che fanno
tutti
io ho ascoltato quello che sentivo
dentro di dover fare quindi me ne sono
andato per un percorso tutto mio che mi
piace definire sperimentale in qualche
modo per fare questo io non avevo
nessuna minima idea di dove partire e
quindi ho dovuto fare un progetto ma non
progetto e allestimenti un progetto di
piazza è un progetto di scuola è un
progetto di case un progetto della mia
vita
e questo progetto l'ho messo solo
partendo anzitutto dai miei piaceri
quali sono i piaceri quali sono le
abilità che voglio sviluppare quali sono
le effettive risorse per farlo quali
sono gli obiettivi a lunga scadenza e
magari a breve scadenza e tirare fuori
una strategia bene questa strategia a me
mi ha spinto mi ha scaraventato talmente
in arizona
in una città che si chiama arcosanti un
laboratorio urbano fondato negli anni 70
da paolo solerio l'architetto italiano e
questo è un vero e proprio laboratorio
nel senso si fa ricerca per sviluppare
dei modelli a modelli alternativi urbani
che siano capaci di supportare un
processo di evoluzione del cittadino
quindi dell'uomo al suo interno che sia
più consono alle problematiche attuali
dunque arcosanti fa ricerca però nel
frattempo anche un bel luogo insomma
accattivante è integrato nella natura
interessante c'è gente a limina tutto il
mondo quindi c'è uno scambio di
informazioni costante arcosanti mette a
disposizione delle strutture quali
falegnameria laboratori del metallo
laboratorio della pittura scultura
ceramica che praticamente chiunque
partecipa al progetto ne può usufruire
bene in qualche modo mi sono sentito un
po come alice nel paese delle meraviglie
e mi chiedevo come diamine
sono arrivato fin qui e mi sono
ricordato di quel progetto che il
progetto che era collegata al mio
istinto al mio cuore alla mia capacità
di visualizzare l'obiettivo mi sono
lanciato ed ora esattamente lì dove
dovevo essere certo in qualche modo
dovuto faticare
perché prima di iniziare a sperimentare
una serie di attività io dovevo lavorare
ho fatto il cameriere ho fatto il cuoco
lavorato come 4 non mi sono dato da fare
in qualsiasi modo però nel restante
tempo libero io mi dedicavo alla pittura
ho iniziato a sperimentare la ceramica
quindi una serie di attività che anche
in maniera ingenua che andava a
raccogliere l'argilla dal letto del
fiume non ha avuto maestri il mio
maestro migliore è stato l'errore il
tentare sbagliare è in qualche modo
messo su un po alla volta delle tecniche
che possono portare a dei risultati che
si tende sempre poi a migliorare nel
tempo
la cosa interessante è che poi entrato
in questo meccanismo si inizia può avere
la capacità e la volontà anche di fare
sintesi di scrivere di pubblicare di
partecipare a eventi come questo come
sto facendo in questo momento è in
qualche modo c'è una sorta di calamita
tra le azioni
succede che accadono una serie di
avvenimenti che non avevi previsto e che
ti spingono ancora oltre quello che il
tuo progetto bene in qualche modo mi
sono ritrovato all'improvviso il nuovo
messico dopo arcosanti a partecipare ad
un accademia dove ho appreso a costruire
nuclei residenziali autosufficienti con
i materiali di riciclo
quindi ho continuato a sviluppare questa
capacità di lavorare con le mani con la
manualità con il corpo in qualche modo
mi rendevo conto che questa manualità mi
rendeva felice quindi alla proposta di
un mio amico antonio un mio carissimo
amico che mi propone di andare in cile
nel suo paese a costruire ulteriori
esperimenti di autocostruzione quindi
quando il progettista diventa non solo
l'esecutore del progetto ma anche
partecipa all'esecuzione dell'opera
mi sono ritrovata in cile ho fatto un
ulteriore esperienza costruttiva mi sono
confrontato con altre persone oltre a
imparare nuove lingue con nuove culture
dopo un po di tempo ho sentito la
necessità di prendere questo bagaglio di
informazioni e di nuove tecniche
sperimentate nuova conoscenza e portare
nel territorio dove sono nato dove sono
cresciuto e solido nato qui in italia a
napoli è la mia idea
era quella di fare sintesi di queste
conoscenze multiple e applicate
all'architettura ad ogni occasione che
mi capitava qualsiasi indipendentemente
dalla dimensione dalla porta dallo
spillo allaga la casa l'allestimento
qualsiasi e quindi anche un semplice
allestimento di un giardino diventa un
teatro per sperimentare determinare
tecnologie denominate tecniche in questo
caso si è sperimentato la scultura in
cemento dove il cemento prende forma dal
terreno non più dalle casse forme quindi
si scolpisce il terreno non si scolpisce
il cemento ma la cosa interessante della
sperimentazione è quella che
l'esperimento non punta all'obiettivo
inserì fine a se stesso ma già è un
passo oltre già sta pensando a come
migliorarsi per la prossima occasione
e in questo caso per esempio questa
tecnica di costruzione è stata
utilizzata successivamente per
realizzare un portale di un edificio che
aveva bisogno di un ingresso insomma
maestoso il budget era basso
la tecnica era esatta è stata
perfezionata la migliorata ed è stata
applicata come anche in questo caso dove
in qualche modo utilizzando la stessa
tecnica ma alleggerita ancora meno
materiale utilizzando anche materiali di
riciclaggio è stata servita per creare
un divisorio tra due proprietà distinte
quindi ogni occasione anche una semplice
recinzione può diventare un'occasione di
sperimentazione così con un allestimento
di interni si è applicata una superficie
a parete dove quelle conoscenze che
avevo fatto praticamente scavando nel
letto del fiume rtrova dell'argilla il
giorno in qualche anno dopo mi ha
permesso di realizzare una superficie
scultorea per un appartamento di interni
quindi ritrovo molto interessante quella
capacità che abbiamo nello spingerci in
territori sconosciuti apparentemente ma
da quei territori riusciamo ad
assimilare una serie di conoscenze e
tirare fuori delle abilità che forse
neanche sapevamo di avere
attraverso una sorta di azione e
trasversale di fare sintesi di queste
abilità riusciamo ad apportare
originalità e innovazione
così come è successo con questo
esperimento di architettura dove in
questo caso non solo abbiamo
sperimentato una forma alternativa di
come concepire una sopraelevazione
qui si trova a polla dove uno scenario
di qualitativo bassissimo a livello
architettonico
abbiamo avuto piantare un seme in
qualche modo a cosa che potesse fungere
da modello da impatto è questo caso
abbiamo applicato alle facciate esterne
invece del solito intonaco disperante
delle pannellature in ceramica
totalmente realizzate a mano dal
materiale grezzo col supporto di una
fabbrica che si trova a vietri di
santoriello però queste facciate non
solo hanno un motivo decorativo
chiamiamolo scultorio artistico
chiamiamolo come vogliamo ma hanno anche
un valore tecnologico perché permettono
la ventilazione passiva degli ambienti
ci sono delle cavità all'interno dove
l'aria passa e sono in grado queste
pannellature di mantenere il microclima
ideale all'interno dell'edificio
quindi di nuovo la sintesi tra le
conoscenze per questo alla fine il
concetto che vorrei trasmettere che è
necessario appunto lanciarsi in
territori sconosciuti per apprendere da
fonti distinte che apparentemente
all'inizio possono sembrare divergenti
ma poi si fanno sempre utili nel momento
giusto e vorrei lasciarvi quindi con tre
messaggi di chiusura e messaggi chiave 3
insegnamenti che ho ricevuto durante
questa esperienza
uno che la sperimentazione non è una
modalità da applicare soltanto
all'ambito lavorativo alla carriera ma è
una modalità da applicare alla vita il
lanciarsi senza paura in situazioni
nuove ci permette di tirare fuori delle
qualità che stanno dentro e che voglio
nemmeno
vogliono uscire poi non prendere forma
concreta nella realtà la seconda chiave
di lettura e che mi rendo sempre più
conto che oggi è il tempo esatto per la
sperimentazione perché mai prima della
prima di oggi mai nella storia si ha
avuto una così ampia capacità di scambio
di informazioni di scelta di circostanze
e di sintesi quindi se abbiamo questo
istinto di voler sperimentare
determinate abilità determinati desideri
ora è il momento per farlo e per
chiudere
credo che bisogna anche ricordare che un
esperimento non è una cosa che si fa e
da risultati subito è un esperimento e
come un seme è come un seme che noi
portiamo con noi ce lo abbiamo qui ce
l'abbiamo in mano oppure magari in tasca
però fin quando sta in tasca rimane solo
un seme nonostante che potrebbe esserci
un albero dentro ma fa dai suoi frutti
quel seme nel momento in cui lo
piantiamo nel terreno e abbiamo quella
capacità di prendersene cura
ogni giorno di innaffiarlo di dargli
coraggio di dargli fiducia di dargli
conoscenza e sono sicuro che prima o poi
l'albero che è contenuto in esso
spunterà grazie
[Applauso]